tickets for the in-person sin Week
events are available through the end of
January don't miss out on your chance to
join the sin crew and the sin club for
delicious food sinful movie watching and
more the live event is in Nashville this
March check the link in the video
description for all the details
[Music]
what happened to me this isn't about you
Jen this is about me I'm having to watch
the same previously ons that were
previously on the previously on section
of episode 2 and that was after watching
the actual scene in episode one who the
hell are you the more important question
is why aren't we seeing more of Titania
yet you've got Jamila Jamil and
you're sticking her on the sidelines for
the first few episodes what is wrong
with you She-Hulk attorney at law wait
she's been to the Super prison once as
far as we know and that's all it takes
for her to enter just a simple flash of
her driver's license shouldn't the card
at a super prison at least check the
idea a little closer for I don't know
security attempting to disguise your QR
codes and fabric but then not making the
pattern stand out enough in the design
that the QR code actually works
surviving nine years in retail who sits
like this next to the window it's a cool
shot but it kind of seems like it only
exists because the director wanted it to
I know you can't wait to see long I get
it Wong Ying the fourth wall also I eyes
on the road please time didn't appear to
freeze when you broke the fourth wall
just remember whose show this actually
is and you just remember to stop making
sustained eye contact with me while I
poop turning Jennifer Walters of Law
Firm glknh can we go one episode without
relying on the crutch of news position
please here's 10 cents for the
inevitable news Position will
undoubtedly see going forward bragging
about your doubloons
this outrage is realistic but it really
doesn't make sense in a world where
superheroes exist internet Fanboys like
this exist in our world where
superheroes are fictional beings and
creative Direction changes every few
years Mike introducing more women or
people of color or queer characters into
Legacy titles so backlash is expected
but in a world where superheroes are
real people not fictional characters
being made to appeal to widening
audiences that sort of backlash doesn't
add up She-Hulk wasn't a character
introduced in a fictional story in this
world she's a real woman named Jennifer
who became She-Hulk through a car crash
in the MCU nobody manufactured her her
so her sudden existence shouldn't be
controversial for this particular reason
um Mr Wong great entrance perfect timing
perfect timing it's almost as if the
writers on the show knew they
work with and crammed as much plot as
they could into the episode I really
need to take this let's recap briefly
here Jen arrived in her office only to
be summoned to another office where upon
arrival she immediately needs to depart
to go back to another office so the sin
as always is the office I extracted him
from the prison against his own wishes
because I were quite a worthy opponent
as part of my training to become
sorcerer Supreme and in a world full of
superhuman and very worthy opponents for
Wong to fight he had to pick one that
was in prison why didn't he ask Thor
Spider-Man or the cousin of the woman
sitting right in front of him and to the
sorcerer Supreme regulations condone
breaking potential worldwide threats out
of prison to fight in their version of
the Kumite because that is all kinds of
up so Mr Bukowski uh how much
money in cash and Gifts did you spend on
the Meg and the stallion imposter I love
the making these stallion She-Hulk
twerking meme as much as anyone but I
feel like there was an easier way to get
to that moment than this uninteresting B
plot where we have to spend way too much
time with Dennis the cliched
woman hungry asshat attorney also I have
now trained Mark the title Dennis the
cliched woman hungry assat attorney so
if you'd like to use that in any way
Disney I'm listening I don't you guys
know me pug says the story straight with
his co-workers assuring them that when
the elf said this I love harassing women
in the workplace everyone knew it wasn't
him but how did he hear the shapeshifter
spew her in the first place the
real pug was in his office with the door
closed is it true you were rejected by
The Avengers
Jennifer Walters also known as She-Hulk
rumored to have been rejected by The
Avengers broadcast journalism this
horrific table that basically demands we
all look at the leg spread crotch shot
of whoever sits in the hot Center seat
but I think we all know how this is
going to go so let's keep this brief I'm
not under any illusion that parole
hearings in the American justice system
are 100 impartial uh don't you have to
at least keep up the appearance that
Emil is going to get a fair hearing when
you open yourself up to a lawsuit of
some kind otherwise I don't think we
need to get into that any further any
other questions
having been involved in several court
cases and parole hearings in which I
will not specify my role I can
confidently say I've never once seen law
officials raise their hands to speak as
though they are kindergartners instead
of toilet wine prisoners make toilet
kombucha asking me to be impressed with
this change when we all know that
kombucha is normally made in toilets I
find it hard to believe that Mr Bukowski
could be fooled so easily my reaction to
watching every episode of Catfish
somehow makes its way into this episode
in light of some new information I have
just received I'm changing my ruling
this shape-shifting character has
allowed for some fun moments with the
cast and I'm smiling despite myself but
I'm not laughing so that's a sin the
Abomination takes off both Crocs then
the camera gets closer and he does it
again this must mean he has a super
ability to recreate Crocs from thin air
and that is truly an Abomination you
realize that you've just admitted to
facilitating a prisoner escape which is
a crime
this works this can go away you know
with one little interview you believing
that one interview on any news station
will clear up anything ever connecting
the A and B story nice only when the B
story is less interesting than the a
story but in this case I'm far more
interested in the cheeky elf we also
sentenced the defendant to 60 days for
impersonating a judge a show about
lawyers demonstrates that it cannot
differentiate between civil and Criminal
Court we find the writers guilty of a
lack of research and sends them to 50
more sins
yeah but you're not her you're clearly
an operating apostle from Asgard because
you were not in that seat 55 seconds ago
I mean why shorten courtroom when you
can shift the word to the empty space at
the bottom of the sign lazy Sign Making
is lazy we hereby Grant Mr blonsky's
release on parole effective in media
Gathering the press the eight soul mates
and all the prison staff together to
announce something that could have been
an email I'm just looking at Jin's face
as She Hulk and I'm wondering if her
makeup just magically shifts to a green
Hue on its own or does she have a green
themed eye palette at the ready just to
keep that natural look in Hulk form so
now whether I like it or not I am
forever She-Hulk great we have to take a
break after one question you want to
know one of the main reasons why less
people watch linear television these
days this this is why these idiots
managed to land a hit or two using the
Asgardian attack but none of the blows
even face She-Hulk in previous Marvel
films we've seen alien Tech was enough
to at least knock Holt down hell Tony
knocked out a tooth without alien attack
shouldn't She-Hulk at least get knocked
back an inch or two show a small sign of
impact nobody expects these guys to
defeat her but if you're gonna go
through all the trouble of showing off
as guardian Tech shouldn't it do
something random Asgardian weapons
thieves survive this which is good
because I don't want She-Hulk to be a
murderer at least I don't think I do I
mean maybe I no no no no no definitely
definitely don't want She-Hulk to be a
murderer hey there's my new favorite
client fun Cameo but why would making
the stallion be one of Jennifer's
clients in the Superhuman law Division I
realize some of the hardcore MCU fans
complain about this show being a little
lighter maybe a little sillier but what
in the hell is wrong with that we've got
She-Hulk and Megan the stallion
twerking loosen up a little have some
fun you and the MCU will live longer not
everything has to be about dead parents
in fact I wish a little less was
foreign
stop looking at me Swan life moves
pretty fast if you don't stop and look
around once in a while you could miss it
sorry you thought you were dating Megan
the style him multiple Grammy Award
winner Mega star Megan Beast out that's
what she said she said Mr Blonsky is
currently in a long-term committed
relationship with several pen pals um
all of whom have pledged to financially
support him excuse me if I could
clarify no I love being the center of
attention because it's really where I
should be and I love the looks my ladies
give me you know a little glint I love
that of course is not necessary so cheer
baby cake she however had time to hide
the gun didn't you Chutney after you
shot your father I didn't mean to shoot
him I thought it was you walking through
the door